- Is it like Jennifer Lawrence?
Because then may--
- You would let Jennifer
Lawrence pee all over your couch
and then lick her wet pants.
- I mean, Jennifer Lawrence.
- The thing about lesbian porn is most
of it is not made for lesbians.
It makes it look like we
have completely awful sex.
- We've got our rubric right here.
First thing on the rubric is storyline.
- Level of foreplay.
- Turned on-ness.
- Nail fakeness, is that
really that big of a deal?
- Then belieability.
- Do you wanna click the link?
- No, I was gonna ask
you if you wanted to.
- Let's watch some lesbian porn.
- Why not? (clinking)
- "Horny Teen Lesbian Seduced by Sisters."
- I hope it's not incest.
- She's not going to join them, is she?
That's her sister.
- What are they eating?
I'm like interested in that.
- Eating Rice-A-Roni and
now they're in the bedroom.
- Do you see what they're
doing with their tongues?
- Now they're naked magically.
- Oh, she's naked.
How did, when did that...?
- That girl just looked
straight into the camera.
- Now they're doing a
human centipede (laughs).
- "Lesbian Teen's Kinky Pissing Video."
- Oh no, there's already liquid.
- Is that pee?
- Is she really peeing?
- [girl in plaid] Oh, okay.
That is so gross.
- [girl in plaid] Okay.
- She literally looks like
she's giving her a medical exam.
What's going on in there?
- Do you need like a flashlight?
- The classic straight girl is like
"Wax on, wax off."
- She's taking her piss-soaked jeans
and squeezing their excess pee.
- Who are they, where are they from,
do they know each other, are they related,
are they friends, do they work together,
are they strangers, did she
just walk into her house,
was she gonna break in, was
she gonna steal something?
Now they're having sex.
Why did she pee on her?
"Busty Brunette Tries Hard
"to Seduce Her Straight Blonde Roommate."
- "Punish my little whore
ass" is what she said.
This is definitely porn for men.
- Yeah.
- Girl isn't wearing underwear.
- Awesome.
- Strap-on happened.
She's ramming her right now.
- By the way, the (beeping) harness
for the strap-on is bedazzled.
- This just looks really painful.
- Okay, now they're 69ing.
- She's literally, she's
just like (spitting).
- Oh, and now we have scissoring.
- Scissoring, hello.
- All right, scissoring has arrived.
- They have this double-ended dildo
and this one girl, she's
like deepthroating it.
That thing is so large.
- It's huge.
Overall, I said not real lesbians.
- It just makes me very sad
that people are watching
these videos, thinking that
this is what sex is like
between two women, when clearly it's,
I don't know, much more than that.
- There's lack of communication.
They kind of go into it and I feel
like people just get the wrong idea.
- It's not real, it's not honest,
it's not for the audience
that it is "apparently" for.
It sucked.
- None of this is real.
Please don't assume that any woman,
gay, straight, whatever would find any
of that remotely pleasurable.